[Music]
Fumito
doesn't this term sound a little weird
you might be wondering is it a tomato or
a potato plant it's actually both yes
you heard me right in this single plant
the tomatoes grow above the ground while
the potatoes grow below the ground level
and how is this made possible it can be
done by a process called grafting in
this the stems of both the tomato and
the potato plants are chosen and then
joined together by tying them this is an
example of plant engineering on the
similar lines when we cut and join
genetic material the process is known as
genetic engineering it's one of the
principles of biotechnology now let's
explore more about these principles in
detail most of the principles of
biotechnology are based on two
Engineering branches that is genetic
engineering and chemical engineering
genetic engineering is the branch which
deals with the modification of the
genetic material of an organism and
which genetic materials are very
referring to we know that it's the DNA
which is the genetic material for most
of the organisms and what about the
remaining ones well in them it's the RNA
which acts as the genetic material just
like in the case of some viruses so
genetic engineering deals with the
manipulation of genetic material moving
ahead with the next principle which is
chemical engineering the name itself
suggests that the principle revolves
around the use of chemicals for the
growth and the maintenance of cell
cultures for this the desired eukaryotic
or microbial cell cultures are stored in
a contamination free zone
further these cell cultures are used for
the production of vaccines antibodies
enzymes and various other useful
products we will learn about chemical
engineering in the upcoming videos for
now let's just discuss in detail about
genetic engineering did you know that
the first ever genetic modification was
done in a bacterium that's right and
later on these modifications were
applied to animal as well as plant cells
the genetic modification can be done
either by adding something new to the
existing genetic material or it can also
be done by deleting something from the
existing genetic material the DNA
obtained after modification is known as
recombinant DNA technically genetic
engineering can be done in many ways
recombinant DNA is one way to pursue it
when genetic engineering is applied to
modify organisms they are known as
genetically modified organisms
abbreviated as GMOs and what organisms
can be modified with this technique
almost all living organisms can be
modified with the help of genetic
engineering what kind of applications
does deserve modifications and organisms
can give rise to beneficial products
consider plants for example with the
help of genetic engineering we can
produce robust crops best resistant
varieties and also high yielding
varieties of many crops this wasn't
short about one way in which genetic
engineering can be carried out the other
way to perform genetic engineering is by
making copies of the genetic material
this is also known as gene cloning in
simple words gene cloning
can be defined as the process of making
an exact duplicate of the genetic
material but why do we need a duplicate
of the genetic material let's consider
an example to understand this concept
imagine there's a new product launched
by a company in the market this has some
really cool and amazing features which
will be of great use to all now is it
fine if the company manufactures just
one piece of course not there will be so
many people who will want to buy it for
this there will be multiple copies of
the same product manufactured on a large
scale to suffice the demands this just
means that making exact copies of the
original product is useful in several
ways
isn't it this same logic applies for
jeans as well a few genes which code for
certain extreme important proteins or
even the newly modified genes can be
copied several times this process of
making exact copies of genes is called
gene cloning and just as in this case
here as well clones all copies of genes
serve many important applications this
entire process of making copies of the
genetic material falls under the
umbrella of genetic engineering so in
this video we learned about the basics
of genetic engineering to learn more do
watch our upcoming videos till then do
subscribe to our channel to get notified
[Music]